what if I told you that fighting two
Watchdogs can actually be easier than
fighting just one with just a few
Crystal dots you can stun and Short
Circuit the old tree burial Watchdogs
causing them to attack anything around
them this sort of mind control effect
lasts for 30 seconds which is more than
enough time for them to kill anything
else in the room this effect also builds
up on the smaller imps but they have to
have enough Health to withstand a few
darts catacomb dungeons are all
throughout Elden ring and this tip makes
so many of them way easier so why do
crystal darts have this effect then well
to me it seems like crystals were once a
part of the watchdog's creation a
glintstone is embedded in the Watchdog
staff for example but more than that the
crystal Dart description reads long ago
it is said that a Golem crafter employed
a similar Crystal tool I think we'll go
deeper into this in a lore episode I
recommended making Chris Crystal darts
for your playthrough when the game first
came out they're quite powerful and
they're easy to make but it always
bothered me then how so many humanoid
enemies have this habit of dodging them
Elden Ring's enemies do quite a lot of
input reading I'm sure you're familiar
with this but the same goes for most
sorceries as well but did you know that
there's an entire class of sorcery that
specifically does not trigger enemy
Dodges these are the night sorceries
Ambush Shard Knight Shard Knight Comet
these are excellent against NPC Invaders
or just bosses like Millennia who
literally won't see this coming but
they'll Dodge everything else
these night sorceries do a little less
damage than their glintstone
counterparts but you know actually being
able to hit your enemy makes these
spells pretty damn worth it sometimes
night sorceries are designed to be
assassination spells which gives them a
really nice piece of gameplay flavor
since enemies can't Dodge them I'm glad
they have that but speaking of
assassination people commonly
underestimate how useful Crouch is in
this game of course it lets you sneak up
on enemies and if you hit an unaware
enemy then you'll do like 25 extra
damage on your first hit but beyond that
Crouch attacks specifically can be
really powerful even if you use them mid
combat this is because Crouch R1 attacks
have you perform the same animation as
your rolling R1 attacks so if you want
access to your rolling attack on demand
then remember you can just input L3 and
R1 to bring it out quickly at any time
and this attack is especially great on
certain weapon classes it can compensate
State for the weaknesses that they have
in their traditional move sets halberds
for example are typically lacking a fast
horizontal swing but your Crouch R1
gives you quick access to one as another
example colossal swords like the gut's
great sword only have horizontal swings
which is a bit of a letdown but your
crouched R1 gives you access to an
insanely fast and long-ranged poke
attack alternatively if you're dual
wielding you can even try a crouched L1
attacks so just consider weaving these
into your playstyle if you weren't
already it can completely change the
viability of certain weapons another
thing a lot of players don't know about
are weapon faints which are actions that
you can only perform with rapiers and
curved swords if you tap the Dodge
button while you're holding a heavy
attack you'll cancel the heavy attack
while stepping backwards and attacking
at the same time which allows you to
maneuver for distance and steal damage
at the same time this backstep attack
has been around since Dark Souls and it
didn't get much play in Dark Souls
either really but in Elden ring I think
there's one exception that makes this
attack really good and that's the Frozen
needle Rapier this Rapier is really cool
it's hard to end its charge.2 attack is
unique in that it shoots a little icicle
at your opponent dealing damage and
Frostbite without even costing you FP
when this is really great however is
when you use this R2 while fainting the
icicle attack doesn't have a huge range
so you can faint at a sort of middle
distance and actually make use of the
back step in kiting enemies around which
is a really awesome play style and I
wish Eldon ring had more techniques like
this these are the sort of little combat
intricacies that I love making build out
of and I have another really good tip
that spellcasters will appreciate so you
would have noticed that spells have a
set cast time right sorcery is like
carrion slicer have a wind-up before you
attack as do incantations like Stone of
grunk however one really cool thing is
you can make a lot of these spells come
out a lot faster if you combo them with
other spells and attacks for example you
can remove the wind up on carrion slicer
if you cast it right after a regular
melee attack or cast it right after
casting a different spell here's a
comparison
as for incantations magma breath comes
out way faster if you use catch flame
right before it which actually goes a
really long way to making magma breath a
viable spell there are a ton of other
spells that work this way and while the
inputs can be a little bit tricky with
the d-pad it's a really fun high skill
cap thing that you can do to deepen the
gameplay of your spellcaster there are a
lot of spells that combo in this way I'm
gonna write my ones that I know in a
pinned comment down below so reply to
that with your own if you know of any
that I've missed now doing this makes
spell casting a bit more of a high skill
cap thing but if you want to make
spellcasting less complicated well I
have just the thing for you defeat radan
and progress below Lim grave here to
find the mimic tier ashes in nocron
everyone knows this summon is powerful
at this point how could it not be it's
just a copy of everything on your
character at the point point it is
summoned even your talismans and
speaking of talismans there's a Talisman
in the game called shabri's woe which
you can find here in the frenzied
Village when it's equipped this Talisman
forces enemies to focus their attacks on
you to the point that they'll actually
ignore your summons completely usually
this kind of just makes the game more
dangerous for you especially during
Co-op but one clever thing that you can
do with this Talisman is to have it
equipped and then summon your mimic tier
and then take shibiri's woe off your
character so since your mimic tear was
summoned with this Talisman equipped it
will now take all of the enemy aggro
leaving you free to cast ranged attacks
with complete impunity this is a really
good way to help increase the viability
of bow builds for example but it's also
a great way to make sorcery completely
broken since sorcery is very powerful
you could even go a step further with
this and give your mimic a great Shield
before you unlock equip it yourself so
if you really want them to tank for you
then this is what you do of course all
of you know about armor alteration at
this point but there are three
surprising facts about armor alteration
that I think a lot of people might have
missed first altering a piece of armor
affects its stats in all cases that I
could find altered versions of armor
offer less resistances but are lower
weight as well so if you're just shy of
having the right equip load consider
altering a few pieces of armor fashion
is important yes but not if it means fat
rolling next in some cases altering your
armor can give it special properties or
take them away the altered duelist cloak
for example reveals its snakes which are
this reviled symbol that makes enemies
Focus their attacks on you as if you
were wearing the shabri's woe Talisman
that I mentioned before as another
example altering the black knife chest
piece removes its concealing Veil which
naturally also removes its stealth
enhancing capabilities if you have any
other examples like this let me know in
the comments and finally and most
importantly for me a lot of altered
armor sets have different lore
descriptions the altered land of Reed's
armor for example tells you more about
the actual land of reeds which is locked
in a miserable Civil War during which
time it has remained alienated from the
cultures of its neighbors
as another example the altered version
of Loretta's Royal Knight armor has a
different description that describes her
Endeavors after she stopped being a
carrion Knight and fittingly the altered
armor set has the carrion colors removed
so yes it makes sense that this armor
with them removed would describe a
different point in this night's life
there are a ton of altered armor sets
that work this way and I just think this
is such an amazing little detail for the
devs to have included but one thing that
I kind of wish that they didn't include
are these chariots they suck that said
the difficulty that you have getting
past these chariots kind of makes
destroying them feel even better and if
you do manage to destroy them you get
really good rewards the first Chariot
you can encounter is behind a stone
sword door in The Fringe folk Hero's
grave back where you started the game so
let's destroy it to do this carefully
make your way past the chariot dropping
down at pretty much every ledge that you
see until you end up at a poison swamp
then take the elevator back up here
you'll have a line of fire to these
giant pots that hang above the roof
hidden in the shadows and when they drop
they explode in Blue Flame so line up a
shot wait for the Chariot to bump into
the wall below you and that is your
trigger to fire you get three attempts
at this there are three pots and when
you do drop it it explodes The Chariot
giving you the odd tree great bow in
return this bow does extra damage with
wholly infused arrows and it scales with
faith as well the next set of Chariots
are in the oritsa hero's grave here
there's a section with two chariots and
we need to destroy these two so to do
that we need to introduce a third
Chariot into the mix to do this run down
to the point right before the locked
door where a third Chariot spawns and
comes towards you use this corpse on the
edge as a guide to drop down further to
some Rafters continue further down in
this direction until you find another
Chariot ramp at this point you can go
further up or down the ramp both will
lead you to this same pillar of imp
statues that breathe fire make sure you
hit it once just once to send it upwards
this pillar also includes the Roses
statue that summons the Chariots and
this will send a chariot spawn further
up to crash so head back up die if you
need to and watch them crash you'll
receive the tree Sentinel armor set and
the Holy Ground Ash of War for your
efforts in galmir Hero's grave you can't
destroy the riderless Chariot but you
can become its Rider to do this you jump
down into the Gap make sure you jump
into this corner here you'll land on the
Rafters and from these Rafters you can
jump down onto the riderless Chariot but
before you do that go inside the window
to loot the gelmere set and killed the
Bloodhound that's two rare armor sets
already which is great then go back to
the rafters and drop down onto the
riderless Chariot this way you'll go
even further down into the lava and
you'll finish the dungeon as a reward
alternatively though you can backstep
down through this lava or Quick Step
through but that's kind of a lot less
fun for number nine did you know that
weather can affect your damage if it's
raining you'll do around 10 percent less
fire damage but your lightning damage
will be increased by 10 in my testing it
was around 10 and these effects even
applied to enemies that were undercover
from the rain so I guess that suggests
that this effect is applied to
everything in an area not just every
enemy that's wet per se this rain effect
is something you should really keep in
mind if you're doing Jewels at the main
Academy gate in Raya lucaria this is
where people do Jewels By the way it
seems to rain really often in Leonia and
Light builds will inherently be at an
advantage here I guess while fire builds
will be at a disadvantage lastly let's
talk about buff stacking that's a great
way to get an advantage sort of
regardless of your build as well
so disregarding Talisman and armor Buffs
which are permanent there are different
categories of temporary Buffs in Olden
ring and you can only have one temporary
buff active from each category there are
weapon Buffs Shield Buffs body Buffs
Aura Buffs health regen Buffs and
stamina regen Buffs and in addition to
these there are some special Buffs that
don't follow any of these rules so keep
those in mind that's Holy Ground and
Terra Magica for example now activating
as many temporary Buffs as you can is a
huge way to unlock the potential of your
character so here are the Buffs that
I've found that basically work on every
character to start you can activate
health and stamina regen Buffs just with
your flask of wondrous physic you just
need the Crimson burst tier and the
green burst tier these tiers are located
here and here next an easy way to get
access to an aura buff is the golden
vowel Ash War which is located here this
gives you 15 extra damage and 15 damage
negation as well and you can just put
this on a light dagger you can activate
it and then switch back to your main
weapon that's incredible as for body
Buffs The Black Guard sells infinite
boiled crab here and then here which
gives you 20 extra physical resistance
and as for weapon and shield Buffs these
kind of do depend on your build if your
armaments can be infused you should
absolutely be trying to use something
from this list
before I go I want to give a huge shout
out to Parry God who edited this video
the water cooling Loop in my PC burst
apart the other morning and I've spent
the last few days getting a new pc and
repairing the old one so I really want
to thank him for helping me to edit
during this time and editing at some
other times as well he's an amazing
editor and he's fantastic at getting
cinematic footage way better than what I
can get so I have to thank him for that
and here's an incredible Channel as well
he's been doing these really amazing
cinematic Half-Life short animations
which are fantastic please go and check
them out and also before I go I want to
let you know that I'm doing a sale on my
display designs for this week only
they're all 20 off but if you check out
with more than four of the designs in
your cart then they're all 30 off this
would be a great opportunity to get four
small displays if you like all of the
designs I have on my store I'm really
proud of these designs and they're all
inspired by the games I talk about on
this channel so check them out if you're
looking for some room decoration but
thank you as always for watching and
I'll see you next time